selon vous pourquoi Bruce tout ça fait
l'actu cette semaine
sur la le décès de ses parents
exactement absolument et dedans il a une
vraie vraie vraie requête surtout vous
allez me dire si vous trouvez ça bien ou
pas regarder ce qu'il dit
médecin du Samu viens me dire ben voilà
votre maman est morte on est désolé on a
tous essayé pendant 45 minutes on a
essayé de la ranimer on s'est éloigne un
tout petit peu et puis là il y a une
dame qui passe et qui me vient
j'adore vous regarder le matin est-ce
que ce qu'on peut faire un selfie je la
regarde et là tout se passe en quelques
secondes je me dis mais j'ai aucune
envie de faire un selfie à cet instant
précis de ma vie mais je n'ai pas plus
envie pour autant de lui dire ma mère
est morte là donc on l'a pas vu elle l'a
pas vu elle sait pas que la scène est
folle parce qu'effectivement je fais
selfie avec cette dame et ça a été très
vite entre le moment où votre vie
s'arrête et puis finalement elle reprend
quoi
exactement est-ce qu'il dit en plus
c'est que sa mort et sa mère est morte
d'un arrêt cardiaque donc c'est même pas
quand quelqu'un de malade tu fais un
prêt d'oeil on dirait c'est très dur oui
mais c'est extrêmement juste qui dit
parce qu'en fait c'est marrant dans les
enterrements on le voit bien on est tous
là dans le recueillement et puis on sort
et puis on vous récupère sa bagnole et
on dit ah bah merde une prune enfin
voilà ça reprend voilà c'est les petits
aléas de la vie et la heureusement et
c'est pas un livre pour rien parce qu'en
fait exactement en contact avec des
politiques parce qu'il militent pour
qu'il y ait un congé plus important en
cas de voilà il a été contacté par des
politiques très importants qui sont en
train de prendre le truc à bras le corps
et ouais avant c'était que les femmes
maintenant c'est les hommes aussi et
maintenant lui veut un congé pour le
deuil bien sûr ouais il m'arrive
exactement la même chose le jour de la
mort où je viens j'apprends à 9h le
décès de mon père à RTL je sors et il y
a des gens qui demandent à faire des
photos et là j'avoue que ça m'a échappé
j'ai dit pardon faut que je fasse vite
parce que mon père vient de mourir le
mec me dit mais ça vous prendra 30
secondes
pas compte ils sont tellement mibuler le
fait d'avoir leurs photos qu'ils
oublient complètement qu'on a une vie à
côté et moi ça m'est déjà arrivé d'aller
à des enterrements et carrément faire
des photos à l'enterrement avec des
petits jeunes qui bien sûr est-ce qu'on
pourrait respecter 5 minutes oui mais ça
prend 2 secondes
on va encore avoir le Sardou local qui
va dire qu'on oui
totalement à carrière mais pas du tout
tu vas dire rien non quand on est vas-y
elle court
avec avec mon ami brusque que j'adore et
ça m'étonne pas qu'il réagi comme ça
parce que c'est vraiment pour le coup un
mec super bien pour tous ceux qui le
connaissent mais voilà je pense qu'un
monde de nez tu donnes au public on s'en
fout que tu es perdu ton machin que tu
es mal au dos que tu es malade c'est ton
métier quoi
ça vient d'arriver tu viens de
l'apprendre de congé qu'on peut prendre
quand même c'est un autre sujet mais
cinq jours qui va être augmenté dans pas
longtemps mais moi je suis pas d'accord
avec toi tu sais pourquoi je suis pas
d'accord avec toi parce que aujourd'hui
je trouve et c'est je sais pas pour vous
mais moi maintenant quand on m'a dans la
rue je suis entre la prostitution et le
jouet c'est-à-dire que les gens
t'arrêtent et tu dises on peut faire une
photo ouais alors parfois c'est même pas
bonjour au revoir
mais tu mets ton t-shirt comme ça je
suis pas un jouet je suis pas une poupée
c'est un métier la télé comme plombier
comme je t'appartiens pas
et ça finit par eh quand je pense que je
paye la redevance pour te regarder
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre tu t'appelles à l'autre bout
de la durée viens voir
ma table ça nous déplacer
la photo regarde avec vous et regardez
du oh je suis moche on l'a reçu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que le sujet c'est qui dit
effectivement que aujourd'hui
et bien un salarié français travaille
dans le secteur privé qu'est-ce qui dit
qu'est-ce qu'il dit oui on dit que les
jours de courgettes on a 5 jours payés
de jours de congés pour se remettre d'un
deuil et il dit on peut pas revenir
faire un travail correctement 5 jours
pour un deuil c'est pas assez souvent il
faut faire un truc horrible si elle est
vide à la maison les les c'est horrible
les cartons et les machins les personnes
qui est mort il dit que 5 jours c'est
pas assez prendre des congés des vrais
congés
quand tu perds un enfant qui est âgé de
moins de 25 ans c'est sept jours vous
rendez compte 7 jours quand on perd un
an de moins de 25 ans enfin c'est où
quand même qu'est-ce que tu vis et gris
à carrière
je vais dire le fond de ma pensée ouais
jusqu'à il y a encore 30 ans ou 40 ans
mais personne n'avait un jour de congé
moi j'avais un mort
on donne cinq jours sept jours on a
l'impression que c'est déjà un acquis et
qu'il en faudrait beaucoup plus ne
m'attends il y a des gens qui mettent
trois semaines un mois faire un œil
congés payés
27 jours de congés payés pour un congé
paternité trois jours quand tu perds un
enfant oui
c'est quand même chose c'est ce que tu
dis quoi il y a un siècle on mourait du
koala
c'est pas bien c'est bien que ça avance
mais on est déjà en train de discuter
oui c'est ça le Minitel c'était mieux
les vacances